[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial duels au sommaire
aujourd'hui encore deux adversaires
d'autres os x le dirigeant libyen
mouammar kadhafi et le président
tchadien hissène habré
rivalité régionale confrontation
militaire et diplomatique qui leur
présidence marque la pire période dans
les relations entre la libye et le tchad
et fait bouger les lignes sur
l'échiquier régional
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation de nos duellistes c'est le
blitz mouammar kadhafi né en 1942 dans
la région de syrte au nord de la libye
au sein d'une famille de bédouins au
cours de ses études secondaires assez
bas puis à misrata elle est fortement
influencé par les idées panarabiste et
la personnalité de nasser en 1963 il
intègre l'académie militaire de bengazi
d'où il sort sous lieutenant en 1965 dès
1964 il est créé le groupe des officiers
unionistes libres d'inspiration
nationaliste et anti monarchique hissène
habré né en 1942 à faya largeau au nord
du tchad fils d'un berger toubous après
des études primaires il est employé par
l'armée française puis dans
l'administration tchadienne remarquer
par ses supérieurs il obtient en 1963
une bourse d'études à paris après des
études à la faculté de droit et à
l'institut de sciences politiques il
rentre au tchad en 1971 le gouvernement
tchadien fait alors face à un mouvement
d'opposition armée nordiste le front de
libération nationale du tchad ou
frolinat que hissène habré rejoint en
1969 le groupe des officiers unionistes
libres organise un coup d'état est
renverse le roi idriss 1er et instaure
la république arabe libyenne avec à sa
tête un conseil de commandement de la
révolution le ses serres dont kadhafi et
le président en 1970 il cumule ses
fonctions avec celles de premier
ministre la même année qu'est la fille
obtient l'évacuation par londres et
washington de leurs bases militaires
dans le pays et la libye renégocier avec
les compagnies pétrolières étrangères
les taxes sur le prix du baril au plan
intérieur kadhafi renforce son pouvoir
personnel et proclame la jamahiriya
l'état des masses en 1977 des
dissensions se produisent au sein du
frolinat hissène habré se rallie à
goukouni oueddei chef de l'une des
branches du mouvement et forme avec lui
en 1972 le conseil de commandement des
forces armées du nord dont abrets prend
la tête pourtant à partir de 1976 il
rompt avec wade et se rapproche du
général félix malloum successeur du
président tombale b assassiné en 1975 78
hissène habré est nommé premier ministre
d'un gouvernement d'unité nationale du
tchad cependant cette alliance ne dure
pas et de nouvelles luttes pour le
pouvoir vont voir s'affronter les
différentes factions tchadienne hissène
habré sort victorieux reprend le
contrôle de la presque totalité du pis
en 1982 et devient président leur
confrontation commence bien avant que
habré ne prenne les rênes du tchad à
l'époque chef de l'une des rébellions du
nord du pays il s'opposait à toute forme
de coopération avec muamar kadhafi le
leader libyen appuyant un groupe armé
rival de habré lorsque abrets arrive au
pouvoir en 1981 de la tension entre les
deux états monte encore d'un cran alors
qu'il ya peu il songé à l'unification
les deux leaders met en place deux
systèmes politiques économiques et
idéologiques absolument différent le
différend territorial
s'accentue entre le tchad et la libye
autour de la bande d'aozou en tout leur
bras de fer dure à plus de huit ans elle
est sera une forte empreinte sur les
relations bilatérales et la stabilité
régionale en quoi consiste alors les
principaux désaccords entre kadhafi et à
bray quel était le rôle du facteur
externe dans cette confrontation comment
les destins des deux leaders ont-ils
évolué après le départ de habré du
pouvoir pour répondre à toutes ces
questions nous rejoignons emmanuel dupuy
président de l'institut prospective et
sécurité en europe monsieur dupuis
bonjour bonjour pourquoi kadhafi s'est
il décidé à intervenir dans le tchad
quel était son calcul d'ailleurs la
plusieurs premièrement il ya une
légitimité historique c'est vrai que
avant l'indépendance
du tchad qui a été acté après la
deuxième guerre mondiale en tout cas la
fin du protectorat britannique à partir
de 1943 il avait un accord qui avait été
signé entre le président du conseil
français pierre laval et mussolini cet
accord remonte à 1935 qui s'est dé la
bande d'aozou à la libye la libye à des
italiens dont sous protectorat italien
donc entre 1912 et 1943 mais il faut
avoir l'esprit que le colonel kadhafi
n'a eu de cesse de faire appel à cette
légitimité un peu discutable d'autant
plus discutable que le parlement italien
n'avait jamais ratifié cela deuxième
légitimité sur lequel s'appuie le s'est
appuyé le colonel kadhafi c'est
évidemment une forme de souveraineté
idéologique une souveraineté spirituel
la confrérie des confréries sanoussi a
donc d'origine
irradiés dans cette partie du sahara un
faisait la jonction donc deux par la
frontière donc et donc de part et
d'autre de la bande d'aozou mais la
vraie question et qui finalement a
justifié l'intervention militaire
libyenne entre 1973 et 1987 faut quand
même avoir à l'esprit que cette guerre
tchado libyenne a occasionné plus de
7000 peut-être même 8000 victimes mais
que bien évidemment derrière tout ça il
y avait un grand dessein de la part du
collège kadhafi un double dessein
premièrement laver les velléités pâle
arabe où les projets unioniste du cannet
kadhafi il a tenté une union ça a duré
quelques mois en 1981 entre la libye et
le tchad on se souvient qu'il avait fait
de la même de là il avait procédé de la
même manière entre la libye et la syrie
où entre la libye et l'algérie qu'il
avait même proposé une fusion une union
entre la libye et le maroc qui
évidemment a capoté tout comme la
tentative de fusion entre la libye et la
tunisie suite à la rencontre en janvier
1974 à djerba entre bourguiba kadhafi
n'a pas abouti
ce qu'elle cela a occasionné ont le sens
où via une grave crise grave crise
pardon diplomatiques militaires avec
l'expulsion de 50 mille travailleurs
tunisiens l'attaquent de gaza en janvier
1980 la rupture des relations
commerciales et la tentative d'attentât
contre le premier ministre tunisien hédi
nouira en 1976 mais derrière cette
tentative échouée de fusion ou de
logique de créer une république arabe
islamique que du reste la syrie avait
tenté aussi avec l'egypte il ya un autre
dessin de la part du colonel kadhafi
c'est évidemment la proche des eaux
logique cette terre donc à la fois
autour de la bande d'aozou et la région
du tibesti est riche en mal hier en
matière minérale bien sûr aurifère le en
magasin il y aurait du pétrole et il ya
surtout de l'uranium tout comme il y en
a en digère et le président que le
président cadets filles coynel mouammar
kadhafi avait cette velléité de se doter
d'un programme nucléaire et pour
évidemment étayé et abondé dans ce sens
il lui fallait de l'uranium c'est sans
doute une des raisons pour laquelle ils
étaient prêts à partir au conflit et il
y est allé au conflit contre le tchad
mais évidemment aussi contre la france
pour cette même raison merci beaucoup
monsieur depuis nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
vous retrouverons à la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détail sur cette
confrontation merci encore les noms de
kadhafi et de havrais sont souvent
associées à une période de confrontation
brutale entre la libye et le tchad
affrontements militaires rivales étaient
diplomatique tout cela a commencé après
l'arrivée au pouvoir de habré au tchad
le tchad ancienne colonie française
accède à l'indépendance en 1960
regroupant de nombreuses ethnies il est
profondément divisé entre le nord et le
sud
le nord islamisés inclut des populations
sédentaires et nomades notamment les
toubous également présents en libye
tandis que le sud à population
majoritairement sédentaires possède des
terres fertiles mais moins étendue quant
à la libye colonisés par l'italie est
indépendant depuis 1951 c'est alors une
monarchie fédéral et pays demeure très
pauvre jusqu'à la découverte de
gisements de pétrole à la fin des années
1950 dès les années 1960
l'administration du tchad dominé par les
sudistes entre en confrontation avec les
populations du nord plusieurs mouvements
armés se forment se regroupant à partir
de 1966 au sein du frolinat le front de
libération nationale du tchad les
rebelles recherche l'appui de la libye
mais rencontrent peu de soutien de la
part du roi idriss la situation va
changer avec l'arrivée au pouvoir du
colonel kadhafi en 1969 qui revendique
une portion du territoire tchadien au
nord justement c'est la bande d'aozou à
partir des années 1970 la libye soutient
de plus en plus ouvertement le frolinat
en 1973 tripoli occupe la bande d'aozou
profitant des divisions au sein même du
mouvement rebelle tchadien kadhafi fini
par accorder un appui en armes à la
faction dirigée par goukouni oueddei
l'un des chefs toubous en 1981 et les
forces libyennes interviennent et dû
permettre de reprendre le contrôle du
pays à première vue nos duellistes ont
une vision similaire du mode de
gouvernance de leurs pays respectifs
kadhafi et à abrest instaure alors
arrivée au pouvoir un régime autoritaire
qui s'appuie largement sur l'armée or ce
n'est que la partie visible de l'iceberg
tout juste après s'être installé sur le
siège présidentiel hissène habré adopte
la fondamentale ou sorte de constitution
provisoire qui reste en vigueur jusqu'en
décembre
1989 ce document lui confie le contrôle
quasi total sur les organes législatifs
et exécutifs ainsi que sur l'armée toute
activité religieuse est interdite la
scène politique et pas son tour purger
pour ne laisser la place qu'à l'union
nationale pour l'indépendance parti
politique qu'il dirige lui même une
différence notable par rapport à la
manière dont kadhafi voyez l'appareil
gouvernemental idéal mélangeant
socialisme et pensée islamique le leader
libyen défend l'idée de la démocratie
directe une sorte de troisième voie
entre capitalisme et communisme
élections parti politique organe
législatif et exécutif traditionnels
pour cela est abolie au lieu de ça sont
mis en place les congrès et comités
populaires présent au niveau local et
national
dès
1977 la libye n'est plus la république
mais la jamahiriya ce qui signifie en
arabe l'état des masses une autre
composante importante de l'idéologie
kadhafistes il détermine largement sa
ligne politique à l'international et le
panarabisme
attaché à l'aider d'unifier les peuples
arabes kadhafi entreprend plusieurs
tentatives de forger une alliance avec
ses partenaires régionaux dès la fin de
l'année 1969 la charte de tripoli
dessine les contours d'une fédération
libye egypte soudan syrie en 1971 le
quatuor amputée du soudan devient un
trio l'union des républiques arabes mais
sans grand succès kadhafi ne se
décourage pas elles relancent l'idée
d'union séparément avec l'egypte puis
avec la tunisie or toutes ses tentatives
s'avèrent vaines c'est à ce moment là
qu'ils se tournent vers le tchad en
janvier 1981 un accord de fusion est
conclu entre la libye et le tchad
présidée alors par goukouni oueddei
impro libyen or un certain nombre
d'états africains soutenus par paris et
washington n'y vois rien d'autre qu'une
menace d'expansionnisme libyen et mettre
la pression sur le tchad qui cède et
refuse l'alliance après lui préfère
utiliser la menace lydienne pour jouer
la carte nationaliste l'unité du tchad
ainsi que la réconciliation nationale
sont parmi ses priorités cependant en
prônant l'unité tchadienne à bray
favorise les représentants du nord du
pays dont lui même est originaire ainsi
le bureau exécutif
l'autorité suprême du pays est composé
majoritairement d'habitants du nord
malgré le fait que le sud soit plus
peuplé pareil pour le comité central du
parti où les habitants du nord
détiennent des deux tiers des sièges
comment les deux adversaires
s'affrontent il sur le terrain quel
était le rapport de force militaire et
économique entre la libye et le tchad de
l'époque quels acteurs internationaux
soutenait habré et où kadhafi cherche
est-il de l'appui
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
au moment de l'arrivée au pouvoir de
habré il existe déjà plusieurs sujets
qui empoisonne les relations bilatérales
en premier lieu c'est le différend
territorial autour de la bande d'aozou
il s'agit d'un quadrilatère d'une
superficie totale de plus de cent dix
mille kilomètres carrés située à la
frontière entre le tchad et la libye
l'origine dès revendications des poules
de la période coloniale des deux pays en
1935 la france qui contrôlait le tchad
actuelle et l'italie gouverner en libye
signent un traité prévoyant la cession à
rome de cette bande déserte trois ans
plus tard l'italie déclare se traitait
caduque sous prétexte que les
instruments de ratification n'avait pas
été échangé territoire tchadien donc je
suis la bande d'aozou est envahi par
kadhafi en 1973 puis trois ans plus tard
est définitivement un excès cet acte n'a
fait que renforcer le sentiment anti
libyen de habré une fois au pouvoir et
fait de la libération de la bande à
ouzou sa priorité absolue
il existe pourtant un autre facteur qui
a enflammé l'antipathie entre les deux
dirigeants il s'agit du soutien de
kadhafi au rival politique et militaire
de la brève goukouni oueddei rivaux
inconciliables abreu a day sont issus du
même mouvement rebelle le frolinat la
rupture se dessine en 1976 à cause
notamment des différentes visions sur
les relations avec la libye habré était
farouchement opposé à toute forme
d'alliance avec cadette waddell oui
voyez plutôt une alliance tactique avec
la libye comme une nécessité pour
s'emparer du pouvoir début 1979 le
président tchadien félix malloum
incapable de contrôler la situation dans
le pays se retire de la scène politique
tchadienne et s'exile au nigeria le
pouvoir se retrouvent donc partagé entre
habré et wendake le premier étant
ministre de la défense est le second
président du gouvernement d'union
nationale à partir d'avril 1980 des
affrontements opposent de nouveau les
forces armées des deux rivaux
c'est à ce moment là que la libye
intervient officiellement à la demande
du président wade le rapport des forces
jusqu'ici favorable habré change en
faveur de weddell qui chassent en
quelques mois les forces de son rival de
la capitale restait seul le pouvoir il
se rapproche de la libye en signant en
janvier 1980 un accord de fusion ce
document est vivement condamnée par très
états régionaux ainsi que les états unis
et la france qui dénonce
l'expansionnisme de kadhafi pressé de
tous les côtés ou a day fait marche
arrière et demande à son allié libyen de
se retirer du tchad hélas le rapport des
forces entre les deux anciens rivaux
tchadien change à nouveau privé d'un
appui de taille oueddei ne peut pas
résister à l'offensive de habré qui leur
ont verse en juin 1982 c'est donc le
début d'une confrontation brutale entre
la libye et le tchad refusant de
reconnaître habré en tant que président
tchadien kadhafi fournit des armements
aux forces armées de oued chef d'état
légitime selon lui en 1983 à la libye
intervient militairement au tchad pour
soutenir une offensive de weddell sur la
capitale
très vite les forces conjointes s'empare
des principales villes du
et prennent aussi une ville stratégique
de l'est abéché la route vers n'djamena
semble être ouverte hissène habré
s'adresse à la france en lui demandant
du soutien paris ne tarde pas à
intervenir craignant une extension de l'
influence les bienne plus de 3000
soldats français avec des avions et des
hélicoptères de combat vienne un appui
au président tchadien c'est le plus
grand déploiement de forces françaises
sur un théâtre d'opérations extérieures
depuis la fin de la guerre d'algérie ce
dispositif jouera un rôle de dissuasion
conventionnelle face à une rébellion
tchadienne soutenu par la libye le
france yves est alors arrêté et le tchad
se retrouve divisé en deux le sud est à
en contrôler par les français le nar par
les forces de kadhafi et de waddan
en septembre 1984 kadhafi mitterrand
s'engage à se retirer simultanément du
tchad l'engagement est respecté par la
france mais pas par la libye qui
maintient un important contingent
militaire dans la zone du conflit selon
de nombreuses sources le scénario se
répète dès le mois de décembre
1985 lorsque les forces de oued day de
kadhafi se lance dans une nouvelle
offensive vers le sud cette nouvelle
campagne militaire dure jusqu'en
septembre 87 et se termine par un échec
cuisant du dirigeant libyen soutenue par
la france l'armée tchadienne reprend
presque toutes les villes stratégiques
au nord mn une incursion sur le
territoire libyen
la bataille est donc perdu côté kadhafi
qui se voient contraints à faire un
geste de conciliation vers son homologue
tchadien le 20 juillet 1989 les deux
hommes échangent une poignée de main
historique à bamako une rencontre qui
fait suite à la reconnaissance de habré
par kadhafi et à l'établissement des
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
états quant au différend territorial
il le sera résolu qu'en 1994 après la
décision de la cour internationale de
justice qui reconnaît la souveraineté de
n'djamena sur la bande d'aozou hisséne
habré n'est plus président du tchad au
moment de cette décision renversé en
1991 par le combat rebelle idriss deby
il trouve refuge au cameroun pour lui
les pires années sont encore à venir
comme d'ailleurs pour son rival les
biens qui restera au pouvoir jusqu'à sa
mort hissène habré ne profite pas
longtemps du succès remporté dès 1989 il
fait face à une tentative de coup d'état
menée par idriss déby un zaghawa
originaire du nord-est du pays ancien
commandant des forces armées tchadiennes
débit fini par prendre le pouvoir en
1990 hissène habré s'enfuit au cameroun
avant de se réfugier au sénégal une
plainte est déposée contre lui en 2000
pour des crimes commis pendant la
période où il dirigeait le tchad mais la
procédure n'aboutit pas après de
nombreuses péripéties judiciaires son
procès a finalement lieu en 2015 hissène
habré condamné et emprisonné pour crimes
contre l'humanité et crimes de guerre il
meurt à dakar en août 2000 21 dans les
années 1990 kadhafi est isolé sur le
plan international notamment en raison
de son soutien présumé à des mouvements
terroristes à partir des années 2000 il
réoriente entièrement sa politique
étrangère et propose de relancer
l'intégration politique et économique de
l'afrique est la fille est à l'origine
de la création en 2001 de l'union
africaine en remplacement de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine il
en est d'ailleurs élu président pour un
an en 2009 il réussi à renouer les liens
avec un certain nombre de pays
occidentaux y compris la france où il se
rend en 2007 en visite officielle en
février 2011 à la suite des printemps
arabes des manifestations éclatent en
cyrénaïque qui se transforme en
rébellion armée kadhafi promet une
répression féroce alors que la révolte
s'étend peu à peu dans tout le pays une
intervention occidentale menée
principalement par les etats-unis la
france et la grande-bretagne est
déclenché officiellement afin de
protéger la population civile grâce à
cet appui les rebelles son vainqueur le
colonel kadhafi fait prisonnier et
lynché et meurt en octobre 2011 la
victoire remportée par habré sur le
champ de bataille est devenu possible
largement grâce à ses deux partenaires
de taille les états unis et la france
formation militaire appui logistique
soutien financier partage des
renseignements à bray a toutes les
faveurs de washington et surtout de
paris
lors de sa présidence le chat devient le
pays d'afrique francophone qui
bénéficient le plus de l'aide militaire
française selon les différentes
estimations
d'ailleurs les intérêts américains et
français n'étaient pas les mêmes au
tchad si paris était plus disposés à
trouver des arrangements avec les libye
washington tentait de faire du tchad en
rempart contre kadhafi la maison-blanche
l'accusent de déstabilisation de la
région est de l'organisation d'une série
d'attentats à travers le monde sous
l'administration reagan
une vague de sanctions s'abat sur le
dirigeant libyen dont le gel des avoirs
les biens aux états unis et un embargo
commercial contre le pays néanmoins
kadhafi ne restent pas totalement isolée
du fait qu'il maintient de très étroite
relation avec l'urss le premier pays qui
a reconnu le changement de régime en
libye en 1969
tripoli a répondu par une volonté de
coopérer dans tous les domaines surtout
militaire selon les différentes
estimations entre 1975 et 1985 la libye
aurait acheté des armements soviétique
pour une somme avoisinant les 20
milliards de dollars ceux ci comprennent
avions de combat véhicules blindés
système de missile aérien et équipements
navals à cela s'ajoute une forte
présence des conseillers soviétiques en
libye qui entraîne les forces libyennes
et parfois même participent à des
opérations militaires conjointes pour y
voir plus clair nous revenons vers
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
monsieur dupuis quelle est la raison
essentielle de la victoire de habré quel
rôle a joué l'aide étrangère notamment
celle de la france parce qu'ils ont ce
n'est pas une victoire du cnt c'est une
victoire de la france parce que la
france est venue soutenir les forces
tchadiennes
je rappelle que la france a perdu
beaucoup de soldats pendant cette
période que la france a toujours été
présents militairement au tchad depuis
l'indépendance et qu'allié massivement
présents sans doute aussi pour
verrouiller sécuriser le tchad dans son
dispositif sécuritaire 1200 des 5000
militaires français dans le cadre de
l'opa sur barkan
le sont au adjamé l'inde ailleurs il
faut avoir l'esprit que le quartier
général de la force barkan se trouve à
djamena et non pas au mali donc le
président andré senna bré sans le
soutien idéologique amical
évidemment confraternel d'une certaine
manière de françois mitterrand est aussi
à l'époque du président reagan il
n'aurait sans doute pas pu se défaire
donc de l'important dispositif militaire
dont disposait le président kadhafi
d'autant que le colonel kadhafi
disposait également d'un soutien des
tribus notamment les tribus touareg donc
au sud ouest de la libye et les tribus
tout au sud est donc de la libye est
toujours d'ailleurs il est dans une
forme de continuité c'est même tribu
toubous soutiennent le maréchal haftar
pourquoi est ce que je vois que le match
à la fin car le marché est en retard et
est impliqué déjà dans ces guerres tchad
ou libyenne qui d'une certaine façon
continue avec la tentative échouée de
déstabilisation du tchad en avril
dernier puisque la l'époque le colonel
haftar combattez dans les rangs de
l'armée libyenne il avait du reste été
pris capturé par les forces françaises
et il l'a fait un peu de prison au tchad
avant d'être exfiltré de nouveau par les
services de renseignement américains
vers les états unis quelle a été la
conséquence de l'échec libyen pour la
région et y at il des échos encore de
cette confrontation aujourd'hui oui c
est qu on les retrouve dans la confiture
alitée ou dans la
stabilité chronique à la fois dans la
botte de la bande sahélo-sahélienne et
peut-être même de l'ensemble de la
région du sahara premièrement le colonel
kadhafi a toujours essayé de manipuler
pour ne pas dire de d'influencé et en
les soutenant militairement
financièrement également les mouvements
de libération nationaux l'occurrence les
mouvements rebelles tchadiens ont tous
été soutenue pour ne pas dire accueillis
dans le grand fais à
libyen c'est à dire dans la partie donc
méridionale de la libye c'est
particulièrement le cas avec le dernier
mouvement donc le fact donc le front
pour l'alternance la concorde et la
transition au tchad avec son chef m'a
dit mahamat ali qui se trouve toujours
d'ailleurs en territoire et bien et non
pas et non plus en est en territoire
tchadien deuxième élément est d'une
certaine façon cela fait résonance avec
ce que je viens de dire à l'époque il y
avait deux chefs donc qu'ils se sont
fait la guerre par dérivation l'un
soutenu par le colonel kadhafi c'est le
cas de beaucoup lire we day et puis
l'autre soutenu par les etats-unis la
france comme je l'évoquais hissène habré
évidemment il faut aussi avoir l'esprit
que goukouni oueddei est actuellement
celui qui est chargé du dialogue avec
les rebelles les appels on appelle cela
le jazz le pré dialogue donc avec les
politico militaire qui aurait dû se
tenir d'ici quelques semaines la doua et
qui a été repoussée de plusieurs mois
donc deuxième élément évidemment le fait
que le colonel kadhafi disposer de
forces armées régulières mais disposez
également de supplétifs les milices
touareg le ministre ou une bonne partie
de ces milices touareg et une bonne
partie de ces milices toubous ne pouvons
plus guerroyer d'une certaine manière se
sont retrouvés à
lutter entre elles ou à soutenir un camp
en libye l'un contre l'autre il n'est
pas étonnant que les milices toubous
actuellement soit des forces supplétives
du maréchal haftar contre l'ancien
gouvernement
d'accord national est désormais le
gouvernement d'union nationale sous
l'égide du premier ministre hamid abeba
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuis pour cet
éclairage aujourd'hui je rappelle vous
êtes président de l'institut de
prospective et sécurité en europe merci
encore d'avoir été là cette partie là
n'est pas encore terminée la semaine
prochaine une nouvelle partie vous
attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]